bonjour bonjour chers et loire bonjour
bertrand bienvenue sur cette nouvelle
édition de diagonale la leçon avec comme
présentateur monsieur bertrand guyard
bas blancs alors aujourd'hui on va voir
quelque chose d'essentiel
mais vraiment très important ce sont les
finales élémentaire on sait par exemple
que capable en cas d actifs et les
d'abord étudier les finales avant le
début de partie ce que personne ne fait
pas ce que le début de partie il ya les
pieds chez nous amuse mais ce qu'on va
voir aujourd'hui c'est la base
et ça sert quels que soit votre niveau
du débutant au à kasparov
disons que kasparov c'est le faire
inculper sport a su le faire il a appris
très jeune effectivement on commence par
étudier les finales avant le milieu de
partie dans un bon plan d'entraînement
puisque ensuite en milieu de jeu on
saura quel final sont gagnants mais
quelle finale sont nulles également donc
dans les ouvertures on saura qu'à 1200
bon et ainsi de suite en fait il faut
remonter en partant de la base est là
c'est vraiment la base
alors là on va vraiment voir l'exemple
le plus simple c'est la technique de
l'escalier
alors l oit la technique de l'escalier
oui la technique du lescat listes dans
sept premières finales donc là que vous
voyez sur l'écran avec deux tours est
roi contre un roi tout seul et là on ça
permet une méthode c'est à dire qu'on a
deux pièces lourdes ça gagne 2 tours ça
fait dix points donc c'est toujours
gagnant quand on a dix points devant
nous contre 0 et là il ya une méthode
très saint etienne méthodes de
l'escalier alors en quoi consiste-t-elle
eh bien on va se baser sur la propriété
de la tour qui est de contrôler des
traverses donc ici vous voyez que les
deux tours contrôle doublement c'est la
seconde rangée qui est ici pointé en
verre et ça va nous permettre une
méthode alors qu'il n'est pas la plus
rapide
bertrand mathieu le jeu optimum le jeu
maximum dans cette version d'anne maths
en cas de coups mais on ne cherche pas
forcément là
expliquer les méthodes les plus rapides
mais les méthodes qui vont permettre de
gagner quelle que soient les situations
tout à fait tout à fait alors ici il n'y
aura pas d' aventure vous allez voir la
méthode est très simple il ya des coups
plus biscornues plus un peu moins enfin
plus pointus plus complexe ils vont
pluri vont plus vite mais vous vous
prendre plus de temps de réflexion dire
que pour trouver les quatre coups qui
vont mater de façon d'un optimum vous
allez réfléchir beaucoup plus que la
alors voyons la méthode très simple de
l'escalier justement on commence par
faire tour à trois échecs
alors là qu'est ce qui se passe ça va
être là tout le thème de la méthode
la tour fait échec sur cette rangée
pendant que l'autre tout contrôle s'est
rangé la nouvelle et deux rouges et
vertes sont contrôlés et le roi ne se
déplaçant que d'une case ici est obligé
de reculer
il ya une sorte de barbelés insérer ces
deux zones là sont infranchissables
voilà les zones contrôlées les sikhs
adverses ont contrôlé le roi noir ne
peut pas aller sur ses 6 pertes reste
donc plus que trois cases
ils sont en recul en donc ici exemple il
vient en d4
nec est là nous allons recommencer le
même procédé
ok tourache quatre échecs des nouveaux
échecs de nouveau cette tour la
contrôlent tout celle-là contrôle tout
et là on recommence on contrôle les six
cases ont fait échec au roi par la même
occasion et le roi noir est une fois de
plus donc on se sert bien des deux tours
une tour pour faire échec pour attaquer
le roi et l'auto qui l'empêchent de
revenir sur ses pas oui il faut utiliser
les deux tours on ne peut pas maté aux
échecs avec une pièce tout seul très
important il faut toujours deux pièces
alors dans ce cas là on utilise les deux
tours pour les finales plus difficile on
obtient on vient d'en utiliser aussi le
roi mais là dans cette finale deux tours
contre 0,2 tour contre rien de tours
suffisant on n'a pas besoin du roi pour
les règles dans ce film donc là une fois
plus le roi noir complètement pris au
piège il monte en c5 et on continue
d'accord l'accès à la méthode de
l'escalet c'est qu'on a on monte au
monde comme ça petit à petit un set
portable
c'est exactement d'escalier sauf que ici
même carrément l'échelle là ce que je
fais un peu de terrain ce serait plutôt
l'échelle dans ce gala avait ici il va
là justement l'échelle va s'arrêter
j'étais prêt roi b6 et alors là si on
fait la faute qui est de continuer à
faire en échec par exemple cet échec là
et là il y aurait wap entourant
puisque le roi s'est en fait s'est
approché de la torah à proximité malin
soit la balance il est revenu près de la
tour et ici on se retrouverait troyes et
tours qui encore gagnant c'est on verra
plus tard
mais c'est pas la leçon ce n'est pas le
cas ici alors après 3 des 6 non attaque
la torah 5
ce qu'on vient de voir il faut déménager
la tour et partir le plus loin possible
de l'autre côté donc c'est un les pièces
lourdes surtout les tours et les fous on
peut frapper de loin sont des pièces à
longue portée oui hein quand on a 20 22
long rifle au sommet n'aura pas besoin
d'avoir le canon sur la tête du gars non
mais c'est ça c'est exactement ça donc
effectivement le cavadee la plus courte
portée le tour fou et dames
ça va très loin donc on part très loin
le roi noir un temps de répit mais là
vous voyez qui peut toujours pas passée
il peut pas s'échapper de cette partie
août de l'échiquier donc il dit en c6 et
maintenant on recommence tour à halle 6
échecs donc toujours pareil les
l'harmonie des deux tours contrôlant on
va le montrer une dernière fois ses deux
ans j'ai donc avec toujours les six
cases qui force le roi noir a reculé
encore d'un cran pour l'heure 17 donc
l'idée l'idée là je t'arrête c'est
toujours de repousser le roi surface on
va le voir mais voilà assister là dessus
en finale avec roy tour contre roye deux
tours contre euro dames contre roy
l'idée est toujours la même il faut
amener le roi noir sur la bande sur un
côté de l'échiquier
il faut on ne peut pas mater un droit au
centre et c'est là où on comprend bien
pourquoi il faut contrôler le centre
même dans le début de partie parce
qu'elle fait un tout se tient parce que
les pièces surtout le roi moins de
possibilités sur les bords c'est ça
exactement sur les bords les bords
puisqu'on est limité donc nous manque
trois cases toujours sur les d'accord
avec un wii donc là on est l'ultime
phase tour j'ai cet échec on continue
roy montrent encore une fois et là c'est
le coût final tour h8 d'accord donc la
feue la ont valu à rationner alors
pourquoi cet échec
donc une fois de plus on contrôle les
six cases autour du roi
sauf que là maintenant qu'il est sur le
bord et bien il ne peut plus les montées
il est au bord du ring
non là c'est ça c'est ça c'est un boxeur
au bord du ring est ici donc c'est il
s'agit bien d'un échec et mat puisque le
roi est en échec et les 5,4 autour de
lui son contrôle et donc plus de
solutions donc ça c'est le plus simple
or white au tour contre roye ça gagne
très facilement avec la méthode qu'on
dit de l'escalier de l'esc et c'est un
conte petit tellement marche comprend
une marche à chaque fois c'est pas on
fait si c est donc toujours repoussée
alors on va revoir maintenant une autre
finale élémentaire oui peut-être gira
même la plus élémentaire donc là il faut
vraiment être concentré ça va vous
permettre de mieux jouer aux échecs
vraiment ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui un
faux faut quand même
non lui il faut toujours mais toujours
mais particulièrement jour là on va
vraiment voir la base c'est à dire quant
aux il ne suffit que d'un pion pour
ligne aux échecs
pourquoi parce que le pion va'a
promotion il se transforme en dame
hélas ici il faut savoir materi croyais
dame à la pro à dames contre roye donc
ici position très simple vous voyez pion
un pion tout seul en h6 de roi et la
l'option donc le pion à vence non
content
par exemple c'est peut être une sim fin
de partie qui peut arriver à tout le
monde
les blancs ont bien joué ils ont bien
joué mais on en gagne et qu'un pion
pendant toute la partie
ils ont tout échange est là maintenant
il pousse le pion pour aller à dame et
poussent leurs pions pour la dame de
toute évidence le roi noir ne peut plus
arrêter les pions d'accord parce qu'elle
est trop loin la guinée trop loin voilà
le pion va se transforme en dame et là
on va arriver dans l'autre finale alors
roi au 7 mai à chf 8 dames
donc là ça y est nous y sommes alors
maintenant de la méthode pour gagner à y
croire et dames contre roy comme
d'habitude on ne va pas chercher la
méthode la plus rapide en nombre de
coups puisque ce sera la plus difficile
à trouver la plus lente
ici il faut optimiser il faut trouver
des comptes qui gagne avec certitude
sans réfléchir
et alors là le coup ça va être de mettre
le roi et dames en cavalier ce qu'on va
montrer maintenant nous croient des six
maires donc le roi lui on explique le
roi lui la tendance à partir vers le
centre oui alors quand vous défendez
cette finale là aller vers le centre il
faut pas tout de suite simplifier la
tâche de l'adversaire en allant au bord
il faut aller vers le centre brossé 6 et
maintenant vous allez voir on va
utiliser un peu la technologie du zouk
gang d
alors là pour expliquer va se faire
tordre posé plein de questions terme
allemand veut dire je pense plus de
coups très fort c'est très fort c'est
hugues 2
eu de coup de traits un train de dresser
le fait de jouer enfin que ses forces et
voilà alors on va expliquer parce que
tout ça c'est mais c'est vrai que c'est
simple mais y'a plein de petites finesse
voilà même principe que d'habitude il
faut amener le roi noir vers la bande
vers le côté l'échiquier donc là ta
technique
ma technique c'est de jouer dam des
quatre alors est-ce alors on a mis la
dame sur une case qui est donc là en
forme de l avec le roi citoyen fait un
mouvement de cavaliers d'accord il ya
une case des différences de kent
comment expliquer ça parce que qui a
éloigné du roi à une distance de
cavaliers qui éloignait dur à distance
de cavaliers il ne faut pas faire échec
c'est ça de l'astuce c'est qu'on ne fait
pas échec puisqu'il si elle fait cher
excuse moi lâche quand je perds bête
mais c'est aussi pour nos amis
internautes tout premier coup tu as fait
échec mais c'est parce que là tu à
centraliser la dame ou alors confié
qu'il fallait mettre la dame sans fin il
fallait se gagne pas c'est vidéo gag
dans cette finale
là on arrive vraiment dans la méthode
proprement dit on ne fait plus des
chèques maintenant d'amd iv le roi noir
doit jouer puisque c'était du tout et
ouais
et là vous voyez qu'il est obligé de
reculer les objets de quitter cette case
c'est un bon là on l'emmène vers un car
est plus étendue plus loin c'est à dire
là il était dans le car et de 4 sur 4
ans et 6 là il va tout changer de place
et dans celui de cinq sur cinq
alors il va en d5 est là on attend on
recommence voilà mais sans faire échec
et à impact cavaliers du roi sans faire
échec
c'est donc là le roi s'en va encore à
noter qu'il peut aller en b 6 on va le
val mentionné donc sur web et 6 bien
entendu on joue dame c4 toujours un
impact cavaliers du roi et ont conduit à
ces sales for sat forte à lui prend des
cas selon lui mais on prend des cas cela
il est encore jay de monter en dessert
et là on monte en c5 il est encore
obligé de s'en aller mais c'est pas la
vente principal on a choisi pour exposer
cette partie ça aurait pu être celle là
ouais on a choisi que le roi au
cinquième coup après adams et royan à 6
donc là on continue la méthode il va
tout de suite à la grande dame est là là
ça y est maintenant une fois qu'il est à
la bande c'est à dire une fois qu'on l'a
cerné sûr qu'on a contrôlé ses étrangers
s'est rangé verte une fois que le roi
est obligé de rester sur ces cases
l'arrivée ne bougera plus de ces trois
quatre là il n'ya plus que celle là
disponibles donc là et là maintenant on
amène le roi pour le coup final 3 6 3 6
3 des 6 ou un 7 roi c7
c'est dire que la maintenant le roi noir
ne peut plus rien faire ne peut plus
échapper on amène notre roi blanc pour
soutenir la dame dans l'échec final
d'anne decis échec et mat ici puisque la
dame contrôler les fameux six cases clé
heureusement ne peut plus partir ce que
les enfants appellent le baiser de la
mort oui voilà le baiser de la mort dans
les écoles d'échecs exactement mais je
crois qu'il faut revoir ça doucement
un nom bien nous allons voir une
nouvelle position nouvel an on enlevait
nouvelle on va fondre
on va en faire une nouvelle une nouvelle
a8 y en a il a concocté une nouvelle il
y en a une autre
alors voilà position de départ cette
fois ci ce n'est plus ce n'est plus une
option qui va là on a mis directement la
dame
9 heures et alors même thème donc ici a
priori c'est une position qui va être
longue à gagner puisque le roi plan est
mal placée c'est le roi blanquer sur la
bande
le roi blanc et décentralisé
décentralisée alors qu'elle est loin du
centre le roi noir lui il est
complètement au centre voilà donc ça ça
veut dire que ça va être long a gagné
mais que ça va être très simple toujours
avec la méthode donc la premier coup
donc les concept l'acheter les concepts
du centre ça existe aussi un final le
centre est aussi important final oui
alors il faut prendre le centre en
finale effectivement puisque une fois
qu'on a pris le centre ça veut dire que
notre adversaire n'y est plus il est
donc sur les bords et sur les bords il
est moins performant et plus et mal de
serre matinale ici au premier coup donc
là vous l'avez deviné bien sûr il s'agit
de entre autres dames ces trois là ça y
est on s'est mis dans la danse
couronnement cavani on reprends ta
technique c'est-à-dire d'abord on sert
de la dame un peu comme une tour
puisqu'elle empêche le roi de passer 1
c'est une tour dames 1 oui et puis en
même temps donc on sera prochain alors
le roi non plus il est malin il reste
aux saintes
il reste certes mais il ne pourra pas
rester longtemps puisque là on continue
encore ouais dame b 4 on ne fait
toujours pas échec il ne peut toujours
pas s'échapper
il faut qu'ils bouchent il vend aussi ce
donc on n'a pas besoin dans cette finale
n'a pas besoin
roy tout de suite voilà le roy on ne la
mène qu'à la fin d'accès qu'on prépare
le terrain pour l'arrivée du roi donc
james est simple qu'on reste toujours là
vous voyez je pense que les coûts sont
vraiment très explicite la ruhr f6 donc
d'amd 5 toujours en cavalier dano 5 très
simple d'année 6 roger vite et là ça y
est on l'a coupée sur la septième rangée
un champ de force donc là le lot
infranchissable exactement donc là
toutes ces cases la tête ont contrôlé le
roi confinés sur deux cas ce qu'on va
compter en rouge ne s'est pas compliqué
à calculer là il ne pourra plus en
oeuvre à partir de ces quatre là rouach
8 là il ya une faute typique affaire à
ne faut pas vouloir aller trop loin avec
la méthode c'est à dire que si on va
trop loin
on va jouer le coup dams est en effet 7
hélas hélas c'est stan wright
c'est-à-dire patate pâte puisque le roi
noir ne peut plus bouger on l'a vraiment
là on en a trop fait on la troupe ont
fermé le roi noir est cerné de toutes
parts il est à lui de jouer il ne peut
pas jouer donc c'est donc parti nul donc
ici effectivement il fallait sur watch
rien que là on amène papa on n'a même
pas mais on amène on avait un trappeur
donc la très simple donc leurs droits
aux échecs droit ces deux le roi noir
lui alors on va rester sur les docks a
rien d'autre à faire nous on va monter
vers le détroit donc la suite se passe
de tout commentaire
on centralise le roi ça qui va passer
par le centre quand je vois une telle
méthode de prion prioritairement par le
sang
il aurait dû passer n'importe quand on
arrive on g6 et la ranger vite alors là
maintenant plusieurs choix de nattes
soit le match du couloir
c'est à dire en profitant du fait que le
roi contrôler ces trois cases on va
asséner un échec ici hop
c'est dire que le roi me faire office de
tout en fait soit le baiser de la mort à
la norme le fameux baiser de la mort
d'alger cet échec et mat
donc c'est un choix donc voilà donc là
je pense que roy et dames c'est assez
clair donc je résume tout ce que tu as
dit parce qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
de choses donc d'abord l'idée c'est
toujours de repousser le roi de perse
d'angoissé finale au fond un déjà dans
cette can à vue et alors pour roy et
dames on repousse
d'abord le roi noir enfin le roi noir
dans notre exemple avec la dame
et puis on amène le roi et puis et puis
ben le prochain exemple on va jouer le
prochain exemple est plus dur puisque
donc on a vu deux tours on a vu dès
maintenant on va avoir encore moins de
matériel va avoir droit et tours pour
mater on est tour donc là allons-y ici
position très simple position de base
c'est à dire que là le travail a déjà
été fait puisque enfin la plus grosse
partie du travail est fait puisqu'on a
déjà réussi à couper le roi noir dans
cette position de base dire que le roi
noir là il est cerné décerné par les
tours donc là on va amener le roi
maintenant puisque la tour tout seul ne
fera pas date de même que la dame tout
seul ne peut pas donner chaque et mat
et si une fois mes droits alors le bon
coup dans cette position c'est de jouer
roy en d6 donc là ça veut dire que par
rapport au final combien de voix il faut
vraiment bien coordonnée les deux pièces
voilà un
c'est très important de l'avant de
nouveaux concepts la coordination des
pièces coordination entre eux autour
alors une fois les ondes et 6 on va y
revenir après ici deux possibilités pour
les noirs la plus simple et en 3d vite
qui est une
ce qui est une faute entre guillemets
pourquoi parce que là vous voyez que les
rois sont en vis-à-vis en opposition en
opposition c'est comme ça que ça
s'appelle donc le roi blanc contrôle les
trois cases devant le roi noir et si
très simple on a tous en a fait son rôle
n'a plus besoin de contrôler ça puisque
c'est le roi qui a pris le relais à
coeur la tour descend tour descend ici
donc le roi contrôle toujours ses cases
larmes le roi blanc latour
elle contrôle les médias manger il n'ya
plus d'échappatoire pour le roi noir cet
échec est l'échec et mat
donc revenons sur la position ici après
un roi d'ys ne faut donc pas les à
droite mais à gauche c'est plus
résistants rendez vite d'accord là les
blancs jouent roi ans ici c'est à dire
qu'on continue on a simplement décalée
la position vers le bord très important
on est en train d'aller vers le borgne
donc là une fois de plus si le roi noir
vient on s'est vite ses échecs et mat un
accord il recule donc encore une fois et
après 3 des 6 l'oeil ne peut plus partir
puisqu'elle n'a plus de gaz
il faut qu'il revienne en baby tu es là
le même thème d'échec et mat tour j'ai
dis donc on le rappelle une dernière
fois le roi contrôle les trois cases qui
sont devant et la tour conclu le travail
alors ça c'est j'ai eu de la chance
parce qu'on va le revoir tout de suite
mais la position précédente peux-tu
larves la remettre
là c'est l'ensemble du département
précédente
nova rencontre montre la séquence voilà
voilà hélas les noirs sont obligés de
jouer un mauvais coup c'est sale luxe
dans la fois peut-être que tu expliques
oui donc non parce que on va employer
beaucoup cette ce terme
les noirs sont obligés de jouer dans
cette position c'est la règle du jeu
c'est la règle du jeu
chacun son tour de jouer voilà si on ne
peut pas jouer on ne peut pas passer
l'un met ses pattes
ouais et si on peut jouer on est obligé
de jouer un objet de jouer et donc là en
réalité les noirs sont obligés de jouer
le coup bas le coup qu'il ait fait
perdre parce qu'il se remette dans une
position des fast food banks et se
mettre dans une poule on est forcé de
jouer et on est obligé de jouer un
mauvais coup au fond exactement donc
ça c'est typiquement le sorgho et ici
c'est exactement
maintenant je voudrais revenir à la
position de départ alors après non dans
cette position là il y avait un coût qui
n'auraient pas qui auraient raté la
coordination des pièces secoue donc pour
hâter la coordination des pièces c'était
le roi en ses six mètres le rohan ces
six nouvelles variantes qui était moins
bon parce que là justement le roi noir
va s'échapper il à s'échapper il va
partir par là il va partir vers le 133
guinée le centre de la 8e rang gibert
l'opposition ont des entrepôts
on peut dire donc le roi noir aurait
tendance à s'échapper il s'est déjà p
s'échapper oui il s'échappe alors qu'en
fait en jouant le coup un roi des six
voiliers que la le roman ne peut pas
s'échapper et ça c'est très important il
peut pas partir en des vite parce que
sinon il sera là parce que là à ce
moment là c'est si en l'occurrence on se
met en face du roi tout c'est seulement
c'est pas faut rechercher l'opposition
faut pas là il faut pas là vous la
vouloir tout de suite il faudra perdre
en prend acte mais mais toute façon ce
qu'il faut lire ici c'est qu'il faut
être fou être cool je vais te cool parce
que de toute façon même si on perd un
temps si on perd un temps on peut
toujours refaire la manoeuvre un faut
pas s'énerver avec des sélaciens un
conseil je dirais psychologique mais on
sait que ça gagne ce cas d'un oui alors
il faut faire la seule chose à l'accueil
va faire attention dans celui-ci a pas
les risques c'est le path
alors il ne faut pas qu'il y ait de
pâtes alors on va prendre un exemple
direct donc après premier cours des 6 à
8 ans et 6 3 à 8 à 6 par exemple ici on
se dit je veux non fermés oui je vois là
il est au bord mais je veux qu'il soit
encore plus au bord on se met à jouer
tout angers 7 ans bessette ça c est bien
là non elle est une énorme bêtise quand
mes objectifs alors puisqu'on en a trop
fait la tour contrôler toutes les cases
autour du roi le roi défend le tour et
le roi noir ici et pâtes tous en mémoire
ne peut plus bouger il est obligé de
jouer il ne peut pas jouer
pat donc partie nulle parties nulles
dans ça c'est important donc là vous
avez vu en fait
oui le piège le problème le risque de ce
genre de finale avec la dame on avait la
même chose si on essayait de continuer
trop loin voilà donc il faut savoir
s'arrêter il faut pousser droit vers le
bord de l'échiquier
ensuite il faut s'arrêter maintenant
donc ici c'est une finale assez
élémentaire la position de départ on
peut la revoir une dernière fois
roi des six bons coups le rendement s'en
va le roi blanc revient et mat et
maintenant on va généraliser un peu ces
finales de tours en partant d'une
position plus dure à gagner
ce dernier l'a c'est déjà donc alors là
on havrais n'a pas véritablement de la
bonne position pour les noirs l'euro au
centre et les pièces blanches sur le
bord de l'échiquier donc ça va pas du
tout ici là pour l'instant
prenez cette position et essayer de la
gagner vous allez voir que ce n'est pas
facile parce que justement le roi noir
est au centre donc on ne peut pas le
maté au centre il faut une méthode la
méthode c'est toujours la même amené le
roi noir vers le bord de l'échiquier
donc on commence par le coupé alors le
coupé ça veut dire quoi
non ça là le même on l'a coupée c'est à
dire que toute cette partie de
l'échiquier que je ne vais pas pointer
peut-être toute la partie mais toute
cette partie là chi chi verte ne sera
plus jamais accessible au rwanda on va
on va s'activer sur un demi z1000 chic
et voilà déjà toute cette partie verte
est passé sous qu'on adore laurent noir
non petit à petit on va lui prendre
toute la zone
on l'est tous ont les touffes on la mène
vraiment une agglo et de gaz
donc là le roi noir donc évidemment la
meilleure défense il reste vers le
centre d'accord on descend maintenant la
tour tout seul ne peut pas avancer ses
arguments la dame à dakar contrairement
là très très important il faut tout de
suite amené le roi l'a alors c'est chez
vous vous pouvez vous amuser
oui c'est un truc vous prenez une pièce
ou même tout seul pratiquement vous
savez que la bonne défense c'est de
rester avec leur au centre et faut
essayer de coordonner les pièces la
montre comment il faut faire parce que
là il faut vraiment jouer avec les deux
avec les deux pièces avec le roi qui est
devenu une pièce active en finale 1 le
roi est très très important finale
évidemment puisqu'il ne risque pas de se
faire mater donc en c3 3 ou 5 mais
maintenant on va tour des quatre alors
là c'est bien çà çà çà çà çà çà çà te
plait ça c'est bien parce que pourquoi
on le coupe maintenant sur deux segments
à la fois donc là je ne vais pas me
revint musée à vous pointer toutes les
castes verte mais en gros on peut dire
que toutes les cases qui sont derrière
ce pack vert elles ne sont plus jamais
ne seront plus jamais accessible aux
rendre le roi et donc circonscrit elle
dansait tahrir le caire et quatre sur
quatre le car est pas mal donc 16 cases
de 64 au début exactement donc la vague
des mises
on prend on prend le contrôle des cases
en plus ils obligés de doubler le budget
sont allés droit au cices maintenant on
amène le roi la pièce active à la tour
ne peut plus avancer tout seul pour ses
cadres le roi noir revient aux cinq la
bonne défense maintenant on amène le roi
noir d'un côté donc on croit en ses 5
une fois de plus donc pour ouvriers la
tour elle était à son maximum
elle contrôle limite déjà énormément le
roi noir elle est restée là c'était le
roi blanc qui est un peu inactifs qui
est monté grossistes et là on recommence
on va le couper d'une rangée
supplémentaire dont on gagne c'est un
peu la technique de l'escalier mais
moins facile c'est mon sillage donc ici
on la vit dans 4 sur 3 régions d'alsace
et son espace vital s'est réduit roy et
sicile des tonnages et de jouer roy en
d6 voilà donc la sas a service saas
réduit roi f7 ont fait un échec on est
cinq donc là évidemment une possibilité
très simple après 3 en 1 8
il est bon de signaler il suffirait de
jouer la tour sur la colonne f sur la
colonne f contrôlant donc là toutes les
cases sont contrôlés au tour du roi noir
pas de choix
le roi noir est obligé d'aller en dvi tu
es là il n'y a plus qu'à finir avec le
nat
donc voilà je ne suis pas gentilles
filles mais ce n'est pas gentil mais
enfin c'est efficace quand même donc
ceci après tour f 5 échecs ils essayent
de l'idéal et aux 18 voilà il rien
changé si ce nom là maintenant ça y est
là il a plus que six caches fine le roi
noir n'a plus que ses six cases là donc
il faut pas bouger la tour il ne faut
pas bouger la tour il faut coordonner
tout ça regardez d'accord à noter je
pense que si le roi noir pouvait dire je
passe c'est quand on peut dire je passe
il serait impossible de le mater a les
crocs à tourner impossible de le mater
alors que là effectivement il est obligé
de jouer donc il faut ranger cette un
tour j'ai cinq échecs son espace se
réduit toujours toujours toujours ici
ils ont plusieurs possibilités on va
regarder s'il va ensuite sur le même
thème que précédemment
quand vous voyez cette formation là vous
savez que c'est gagné le roi qui
contrôle les trois cases là la tour qui
contrôle ça donc là il faut penser en
termes de complexe de case là on
contrôle cinq cases autour du roi noir
le prochain coup dur point noir s'il ne
se passe rien c'est forcément d'aller
sur la case à 8
donc c'est une gang ces deux exemples
ici il faut donner le très haut noir
valeurs trop noir donc sans changer la
position tour j'ai un parfait 3,8 forcé
tour j'ai vite la presse est une sorte
de switch back la tour voilà exactement
ça ce que tu veux avec ce qui veut dire
on emploie des termes techniques aux
échecs ses allers-retours ses ouailles
ses managers tour donc après tour g5
partiront en fuite ça se mettrait dans
le complexe perdant rouages 6 la très
simple bref si ce donc là le roi noir
donc qu'il y avait au début
64 cases oui/non n'a plus que trois
enfants il est enfermé dans un complexe
de trois cases ou à vii et là vous voyez
là une des méthodes pour gagner la
partie pour terminer par un matt rapide
ça va être de se mettre dans ce mode
pour cette position on joue toujours à
chaque échec
elle ne peut plus partir à droite de
l'échiquier
il est obligé de revenus en g8 et la
tour maintenant ça y est on est dans la
configuration tour joue je veux tout
tous les coups de tours sur la colonnade
chauffe
enfin tous les côtés mon sauf ceux qui
luttent la tour
les mettre là toi un peu d'un an mais
c'est un pas important de 10,8
voilà et si tourache fuite échec et mat
d'accord donc alors on revient parce que
c'était il d'abord il faut s'entraîner à
ça au début tout le monde s'est entraîné
à ça alors d'ailleurs win pour vous un
petit garçon tu t'entraînes est bien sûr
il faut s'entraîner pourquoi parce que
si on joue des parties blitz des parties
rapides
il faut savoir le faire vite il faut
s'entraîner pour pas faire patte ça
serait dommage de perdre un demi point
alors qu'on a dominé toute la partie et
en plus ça se travaille c'est à dire que
la position y croit et dames entre roy
pour la gagner il faut à peu près cinq
secondes maximum
j'aime bien me serais dit s'il ya
simplement des points donc évidemment je
vous invite à vous entraîner à lorgues
un site qui est très bien pour ça ouais
c'est www.pur.fr nal point net
ouais vous cliquez sur entraînement et
là vous pouvez vous entraîner
il ya une petite applet java roi et où
encontre trois rois dames contre roye
royer deux tours contre roy tout y est
vous bouger les pièces et vous essayez
vous essayez par vous même c'est un
complément parfait pour pour cette leçon
en tout cas bon alors qu'est-ce qu'on
comment on peut généraliser bon déjà
visiblement là on vient de voir des
finales c'est l'activité du roi qu'est
ce que tu peux dire sur l'activité du
roi en finale l'activité du roi le roi
plus efficace quand il est au centre
puisque au centre novas contrôlé huit
cases autour de lui alors quand il est
sur la bande ou voir même dans un coin
une en contrôle que trois ou cinq hommes
alors au début de partie je joue mon roi
je me mets au centre au final c'est donc
voilà on peut dire ça on peut dire que
préparent les finales sauf qu'au début
de partie il ya la dame les deux tours
les cavaliers des fous tout ça ça va
faire des échecs et même en milieu de
partie ce qui prime c'est pas l'activité
du roi c'est la tap contre le roi
d'accord d'un se vaut mieux cacher leur
camp ben voilà il vaut mieux que local
et donc l'utilisation donc tour et dames
avec roy gagne alors voilà justement
j'irai donc c'est là la question qu'on
ne jamais poser enfin que le c'est un
des thèmes de la leçon d'aujourd'hui
quels sont les finales gagnante et les
finales nul sachant que quand il n'y a
plus de pions alors ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui c'est que roy et dames ça
gagne rouler deux tours ça gagne qui
peut le plus peut le moins aux atours
gagne aussi
ce qui est important de savoir c'est
qu'un roi une pièce mineurs çà ne gagne
pas c'est lé roi et cavaliers contre
euro et gagne pas moi qui avais
contrepoint nuggets par walf ou contre
roanne
et pas non plus et c'est important roy
de fou alors oui roi de fou samat assez
facilement alors avec la méthode de
l'escalier une méthode plus évolués
puisqu'elle se passera en diagonale
d'accord on y reviendra
roy et deux cavaliers ça ne date pas là
là commença sa main droite aux cavaliers
ça fait 6 points mais ces parties nulles
ça ne m'atteint pas c'est une exception
je dirais à la morale et chicken nice
côte avec deux cahiers plus ne peut pas
gagner c'est là c'est la seule exception
qu'il faut connaître c'est la seule
exception ou avec deux pièces +13 contre
un roi on arrive à gagner
voilà donc alors on répète choix que
c'est très très important roi et dames
gagne contre roye retour roy est de fous
roi fou et cavaliers ça c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué en revanche trois
cavaliers contre euro à un roi il faut
qu'entre roi c'est nul c nul est roi et
de carrier contre 3,6 l'alsace exception
c'est un match nul bas donc là je pense
qu'on a fait le tour de toutes ces
finales
vous savez maintenant mater avec coixet
tour et bientôt vous serez ma télé
croyais de fouet avec royal font
cavalier ça sera le thème d'une
prochaine de son bon bah il ne reste
plus qu'à se dire au revoir pour une
prochaine émission avec éloi rush et
moi-même de diagonale tv la de sang